Welcome to the MeetingScheduled
outbound operation system where
I'm going to show you
the software that I've built
and what it is capable
to do.
It's going to take a
few minutes but you will
see all the capabilities and
what you can do with
it.
So the user received access
to MeetingScheduled.
He would have his websites
already integrated in the
workspace so the system would
scrape the website and maybe
an additional contact we gave
him like a PDF or
text and basically it organized
the value proposition the case
studies and the product or
service that we're going to
sell then the user would
go down would add this
email signature decides on the
volume he wants to reach
out per day and adjust
the schedule based on the
time zone now once we're
done we can go to
search and we can tell
the system find me 10
IT managers in Sydney.
It would begin a search.
The system is connected on
the back end with variable
sources where it is able
to find live signals,
write prospects and it's really
one of the most advanced
technologies out there to find
prospects that may be relevant
for the service or the
product you're offering.
Once it's done,
we're able to see the
prospects, we can check them
out, and then if we
decide that they're good or
not, then we can go
and begin the output sequence.
The system would enrich the
prospect, it would research,
it goes to each prospect,
it does a complete research,
tells us why this person
may be relevant for us,
gives us the signals and
the outreach angles that we
can do.
Now the emails are being
generated by the system based
on the research and based
on what it learned about
your service
and it creates the emails.
The emails can be sent
automatically in this time frame
or simply have it paused
until we check them and
approve them.
Each cadence has three emails.
First email follow -up
and last email all these
emails there are intelligently
built up on the previous
interaction
the user is also able
to go and connect with
the person on LinkedIn the
system already generates the
message so all you need
to do is click on
add note command V or
control V and click on
send we can send a
regular WhatsApp message or we
can call the person.
In MeetingScheduled you're able
to
have complete
call capabilities so the system
is connected to different
numbers that you pre -purchase
and then you can call
from them.
You can see the recordings
of your calls,
you can play the recordings,
download
pretty much anything you want
and when you have like
a follow -up that you
want to do you can
write it down and add
it directly to your calendar
gonna be integrated directly
with your calendar and bring
all the information there
and once it's all tuned
and set up you can
start an autopilot
where you decide how many
prospects you would like to
reach a day you look
to the schedule matches your
right schedule and that's it.
The system, once you click
on save changes,
the system would automatically
find the prospects,
enrich them, research each one
and begin to outreach them
with the first email,
the second email if they
don't respond and the third
email.
When they do respond,
you're able to see it
in the system and the
sequence automatically stops.